قبل أربعة أشهر ، كان قلب بيروت
مكتظًا بالمحتجين الذين يطالبون
بإسقاط النخبة السياسية القديمة ، اليوم
، اختفت الحشود ، وقد بذلت الدولة
قصارى جهدها لفصل نفسها عن
الشارع ، لكن الاشتباكات العرضية بين
المتظاهرين وقوات الأمن
أظهرت مدى هشاشتها.  هذه الجدران هي
شتاء لبنان المشتعل من
السخط وقد يتبعه ربيع
من الغضب وخطر الجوع من الجوع.
الذروة من حيث الجوع في مجمله ،
ربما بسبب الاضطرابات ، تدهور
الأوضاع الأمنية الهائل ، فقد علامة الهجرة
دوريتو وظيفته مؤخرًا ، والآن
يقوم ببيع السندويشات في
ساحة الشهداء ، مركز الاحتجاجات في بيروت ،
نشر هو وآخرون نسخًا من
شهاداتهم الجامعية على
المتاريس.  الشارع من مكتب
رئيس الوزراء هذه الانتفاضة على حد
قوله هي أمله الأخير حتى د  إن استخدامهم
بأمان لمركبة ناش وإمكانات
ليست حول
صالون المانجا والأرقام التي
أشاد بها البلد ذات يوم لأن سويسرا
الشرق الأوسط على وشك أن تصبح
دولة فاشلة ،
فالعملة اللبنانية التي
خسر زعيمها أكثر من 60٪ من قيمتها مقابل
ارتفع سعر الدولار في السوق السوداء في
بلد يستورد أكثر من 80 في
المائة مما يستهلكه وفقًا
لجمعية المستهلكين اللبنانيين ،
ارتفعت الأسعار بنحو 45 في
المائة منذ اندلاع الاحتجاجات الجماهيرية
في أكتوبر الماضي ، بينما انخفض
متوسط الرواتب الشهرية في نفس ال
ترة.  بنسبة 40 في
المائة ، تعد الحكومة الجديدة
بمعالجة الأزمة بسرعة عن طريق خفض
أسعار الفائدة ، وإعادة هيكلة القطاع العام
وطلب المساعدة من المانحين الأجانب ،
لكن النشطاء في يلماز لي مثل
كثيرين غيرهم لا يؤمنون بقدرة
السياسيين على تجنب الكارثة
طالما هم وهم كذلك.
سيتسبب الانهيار الاقتصادي في استمرار
الجوع وسيتصاعد فقط بالطريقة
التي  سوف يتم عرض الجوع
في الشوارع وقد يكون
عنيفًا وقد يكون مدمرًا وكل هذا
الدمار الذي يمكن أن يندلع سيكون
مسؤولية تلك
الأحزاب السياسية التي رفضت الاستماع إلينا
عندما أخبرناهم أننا سنواجه
إفلاسًا اقتصاديًا  لحظة
الحساب ليست مسألة ما إذا ولكن
فقط عندما بن ويدمان سي إن إن